[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
bienvenue sur cette nouvelle vidéo alors
cette vidéo c'est inscrit dans la
semaine de la classe inversée en fait
partout en europe francophone
les enseignants qui pratiquent la classe
inversée ouvrent les portes de leur
classe et il y aussi différentes
activités qui sont proposées
personnellement j'ai envie de faire
quelques vidéos pour vous témoigner de
ma pratique de la classe inversé il
existe évidemment déjà beaucoup de
vidéos qui expliquent ce qu'est la
classe mrc je ne pars faire une énième
vidéo qui explique tout ça je vous mets
ici peut-être juste le lien vers
quelques vidéos intéressantes sur la
classe inversée ici s'agira vraiment de
vous témoigner de ma pratique au jour le
jour de la casse inversée mais
évidemment vous pouvez toujours me
contacter pour avoir plus d'information
plus de choses concrètes comme par
exemple les supports que j'utilise ça je
vous répondrai avec plaisir j'aimerais
dans cette première vidéo consacrée à la
classe inversée dans le cadre cette
playlist l'école 2.0 c'est vous dire
pourquoi je pratique la casse à la c est
ce que j'en fais l'objectif principal et
c'est vraiment ça le but premier de la
classe inversé c'est pas du tout
d'utiliser de la technologie ou de faire
le prof geek mais l'idée c'est vraiment
de mettre les élèves en actions de
mettre les élèves au travail en
utilisant la technologie du moment c'est
resté un freiner qui est là lui il a
utilisé l'imprimerie pour faire comme
dédé des journaux de classe comme des
petites revues des choses comme ça avec
ses élèves afin de vraiment leur
apprends usage du français lusage de
différentes matières la pratique de
différentes matières aussi des
comportements la vie en société le fait
de prendre des décisions dans un projet
de groupe
je m'inscris vraiment dans les pas de ce
grand pédagogue l'idée c'est d'utiliser
la technologie du moment alors
technologie du comment du moment c'est
quoi mais c'est d'abord tout ce qui est
numérique les vidéos mais aussi les
outils de partage des outils google
qu'on va développer dans le cadre de
cette playlist l'école 2.0 mais la
technologie du moment c'est aussi le
papier 1 on va utiliser du papier mais
quand c'est utile
voilà donc la classe inversé c'est pas
un dogme c'est pas on utilise du
numérique et on fait abstraction du
papier non utilisent les outils
quand ils sont le plus utiles tout ça au
service de la mise en activité des
élèves en classe selon une tradition
socio constructiviste les élèves vont
être mis au travail alors pour des
travaux individuels mais le plus souvent
de groupe ou même des des présentations
sa soul / dut
bon sens le forgeron il n'apprend pas en
écoutant quelqu'un qui parle
assis sur une chaise il n'apprend pas en
lisant un livre n'ont ni en regardant
une vidéo
ça serait complètement débile de penser
qu'on devient maître d'une technique
simplement en regardant une vidéo non il
l'apprend en forgeant en étant actif et
c'est exactement ce qu'on veut faire et
que les élèves
on veut leur apprendre les sciences
sociales la géographie mais ça pourrait
être n'importe quelle discipline on les
pratiquants en faisant de la géographie
en faisant des sciences sociales
et ça ça se fait en classe c'est en
pratiquant qu'on apprend et on en a
l'expérience tous les jours vous avez
sans doute plus appris quand vous avez
conduit
concrètement vous même qu'en lisant les
bouquins qui vous explique comment
conduire le code de la route ou
simplement le mode d'emploi de votre
voiture évidemment c'est en faisant les
choses qu'on apprend le mieux bien
évidemment tout apprentissage nécessite
implique des prérequis toutes
disciplines suppose l'utilisation d'un
vocabulaire précis toute pratique
nécessite l'acquisition de savoir faire
technique la vidéo où les cris qui la
remplace ou la complète va permettre de
placer ces différents éléments au moment
où l'élève en avoir besoin pour en faire
l'acquisition
et pour les utiliser dans une production
plus ambitieuse et c'est au cours de ses
activités là que vraiment
l'apprentissage va s'opérer
on aura semer une graine avec les vidéos
ou avec les textes où les fiches
techniques qui doivent être lus à la
maison et cette graine va germer en
classe on fera tout pour lui donner
l'engrais et pour l'arroser comme il
faut pour qu'elles soient dans les
meilleures conditions pour germer
évidemment il restera toujours des
élèves qui ne voudront pas qu'ils
n'auront pas suffisamment de motivation
qui auront un contexte qui fait que
l'école n'est peut-être pas une priorité
c'est déjà le cas avec l'école on va
parfois reproché à l'école numérique à
aux classes inversée des choses qu'on ne
reproche pas l'école classique l'école
classique est quelque chose qui
fonctionne de manière très imparfaite
si vous voulez des exemples je peux vous
en donner mais je ne donnerai pas dans
cette vidéo si ça serait beaucoup trop
longs bruns et puis j'ai dit que je
faisais des vidéos assez courtes pas des
vidéos de quatre heures ce qu'il
faudrait beaucoup de temps pour
développer tout ça et donc ne reprochons
pas à la casse inversée ce que nous ne
reprochons pas à l'école que sa classe
inversée va permettre différentes choses
tout d'abord il ya des choses qui vont
nous être permise en amont
du coup redon qui a la classe l'inversé
qui va tomber juste avant un court la
première chose c'est la mise en place de
notion de concept théorique donc on a
vraiment envie de placer un concept très
très important et on veut que les élèves
utilisent directement en classe c'est
par exemple ce que j'ai fait avec cette
vidéo sur la corée du nord et en
particulier la vidéo traitait de la
dissuasion nucléaire et je voulais
vraiment les élèves utilisent ce concept
directement classe qui comprennent bien
toute l'importance de ce concept
et pour ceux qui n'avaient pas compris
que je puisse directement bien leur
expliquer aux classes on peut aussi
utiliser la classe inversée en amont
pour l'acquisition en tout cas la mise à
en place de certains savoirs faire par
exemple en géographie on veut pas faire
de nos élèves des cartographes ou des
géographes
donc si je veux qu'ils utilisent la
carte de la meilleure des manières qui
soit parce qu'ils doivent produire une
carte à la fin du dispositif de cours eh
bien je leur donne tous les outils en
amont il les voit on en parle en classe
et hop ils peuvent directement passer à
la réalisation de leur carte sur base
d'activité préliminaire qui ont été déjà
réalisés aussi on peut aussi utiliser la
classe inversée pour des rappels souvent
on passe au mois de septembre à faire
des rappels de l'année précédente
surtout un con air toujours dans le même
degré on est en quatrième
il ya des acquis de la troisième convoi
a été visé alors on passe tout le mois
de septembre à faire de la vision dont
on peut utiliser la classe inversée
bouffe c'est très facile à mettre en
place
on fait ça en 15 jours et on peut
commencer directement une séquence en
classe et pas perdre du temps avec
toutes ces révisions utile mais
chronophage
on peut aussi utiliser la classe à
verser avant le court pour simplement
placer quelques savoirs nécessaires à la
compréhension de ce qu'on va faire en
classe mais qui ne sont pas du tout
important qu'ils sont vraiment
secondaires par exemple ça peut être
comme un historique alors l'histoire que
c'est important mais c'est l'objet du
cours d'histoire donc mon cours de
géographie
par exemple je veux juste que les élèves
comprennent c'est quoi la colonisation
ils l'ont vu en histoire où ils n'ont
pas encore vu la petite vidéo sur la
colonisation pour qu'ils aient bien on
idée tout l'historique par exemple quand
va et qui lit on va étudier certains
conflits géopolitiques
il est impensable de ne pas comprendre
des conflits géopolitiques sans
s'intéresser à l'histoire du pays
voilà mais j'ai pas envie de faire en
classe et un cours d'histoire sur par
exemple l'histoire de la série donc
petite vidéo sur la géopolitique sur
l'histoire
les années 60 des années soixante à 2002
la syrie et le tour est joué
maintenant la classe inversée peut
arriver pendant ou après le court
pendant c'est très rare j'y reviendrai
alors ça peut être après le court parce
que voilà on vient de terminer une
séquence les élèves ont par exemple fait
un tableau de synthèse et on aimerait
vraiment les marquer et leur dire voilà
ce qui est important c'est ça à retenir
pour l'examen c'est ça et bien up
la vidéo nous permet vraiment de
reprendre tout ce qu'ils ont déjà
découvert par à même de manière
intuitive en faisant des travaux en
échangeant avec les autres en lisant des
documents en classe mais hop voilà
finalement maintenant c'est un test
qu'est ce que vous devez retenir paf on
leur met la classe inversée puisque
j'aime bien aussi quand il ya eu des
séquences très complète c'est le cas en
géographie en 4e parce qu'en géographe
et en quatrième on voit à la fois de la
géologie
alors ça c'est super compliqué pour les
élèves la climatologie oh là là n'en
parlons pas les mouvements de la terre
toutes des choses
les élèves ont vraiment beaucoup de
difficulté à comprendre
donc là on peut vraiment faire une
synthèse du coureur séances de cours de
pourrait capter toute une séquence on
peut faire une synthèse et leur proposer
sa voix là pour remettre vraiment tout
le continuum tout le processus tout le
déroulé de la séquence bien en tête
qu'ils comprennent bien
vraiment tous les liens que tout ça ait
du sens pour eu toutes ces activités
parcellaire qu'ils ont fait en 50
minutes 20 minutes une activité puis 30
minutes puis la fois suivante hop à 50
minutes
1 il ya eu le cours de gym le groupe
français cours de néerlandais entre eux
est bien là vraiment la vidéo va
permettre de refaire du lien par rapport
à tous de faire un rappel finalement et
un récapitulatif en même temps c'est ce
que j'ai fait avec cette vidéo sur les
méandres de l'amazone où je fais
vraiment j'avais fait des expériences en
classe et on les a refait via la vidéo
est là les élèves peuvent revoir ça et
se dire ah oui oui il avait fait ça
parce que ça permettait d'expliquer ça
par exemple
alors on constate quand je vais voir les
statistiques des vidéos de consultation
des vidéos qu'il ya des pics de
fréquentation avant les examens donc
c'est bien la preuve que les élèves un
mois je ne les oblige pas revoir les
vidéos en examen mais à des élèves qui
retourne voir les vidéos avant les
externats alors moi je les compte je
conseille généralement de ne pas tout
regardé parce que ce qu'ils ont bien
retenu quoi les revoir la vidéo mais par
exemple je relis mais n'a toujours relie
le syllabus du court
par ce contrat avec un syllabus au cours
de géographie par exemple je relis le
syllabus à la je remarque je comprends
plus ah mais là le prof a mis sur la
feuille d'objectifs des examens qui
avait une vidéo disponible je retourne
voir la vidéo et on voit que ça marche
parce que les courbes montre vraiment
une sur fréquentation avant les examens
les vidéos vont aussi permettre aux
élèves en retard aux élèves qui ont été
absents aux élèves déscolarisés aux
élèves qui viennent d'un autre
établissement de se remettre à niveau
tout doucement
1 ça arrive souvent par exemple sciences
sociales c'est une option les élèves
change d'option en cours d'année et puis
il élève arrive en sciences sociales il
connaît rien des sciences sociales et
bien je le mets devant un ordinateur en
classe ma main où il peut faire ça chez
si celui-ci n'a pas finir aux classes il
termine chez lui voilà tu prends note de
ce qui est important de ce qui est à
l'écran tu regardes bien tu repasses la
vidéo une deuxième fois si tu n'as pas
compris
et comme ça ça me permet vraiment de
continuer le court avec le reste de la
classe mais que l'élève qui arrive dans
l'option ou qui a été absent ne soient
pas perdus je vais vraiment là on va
vraiment injecté massivement et de
manière très très court très rapide mais
très précises tous les savoirs qui vont
être indispensables évidemment il faut
gérer parce que si on lui demande de
visionner deux heures et demie de vidéos
ça va pas être très rentable mais on
peut sélectionner l'enseignant peut
sélectionner quatre cinq vidéos de 5 10
minutes voilà on à l'heure de 50 minutes
qui est complète lui dire voilà ça c'est
ce qui est essentiel et on peut même lui
prévoir un petit questionnaire ou une
petite interro cours suivants vraiment
là de manière totalement différencier
dans le même ordre d'idée imaginons qu
indépendant un cours bloc vraiment sûr
sur un concept bloc sur un savoir-faire
il est incapable de calculer une
longitude et de latitude up vient ici
mon coco on leur met devant une vidéo
est là très rapidement il peut on peut
essayer de remédier évidemment aux
lacunes ce tableau récapitule tout ce
qui vient d'être dit
évidemment certains d'entre vous diront
oui mais si je fais ça moi je connais
mes élèves ils vont ils vont peut-être
pas accroché oui mais s'ils n'accroche
pas la vidéo c'est qui n'accroche sans
doute pas la chose scolaire en général
si vous avez bien compris tout ce que je
viens de dire finalement les vidéos
montrer aux élèves ne sont jamais dans
la classe si ce n'est pour de la
remédiation à un cas particulier un
élève ou l'autre qui regardent les
vidéos pendant que les autres continuent
à travailler c'est vraiment pour
exporter le cours à l'extérieur de la
classe alors ça ne veut pas dire non
plus que je ne fais pas aux classes de
cours ex cathedra où je n'explose pas
moi même parfois la théorie sur les
choses qui sont vraiment très importante
où la boue je devrais pas le dire parce
que c'est pas très pédagogique où les
jeux sont moi qui me plaisent beaucoup
ben je les fais vraiment en direct quand
je sais que la façon de faire la passion
je vais pouvoir mettre en place va être
au service de l'apprentissage mais il ya
aucun dogme ça si vous avez bien compris
le sens à vidéo il ya aucun dogme
évidemment la classe aussi aux inversé
est au service de la mise en action des
et les seuls visionnage n'a aucun effet
les élèves ont regardé la vidéo il va
rien se passer
donc il faut vraiment que le visionnage
de la vidéo ou de la lecture du texte
parce qu'encore une fois ces deux choses
sont interchangeables
il faut que ça soit inscrit dans un
scénario dans une séquence de course
dans un parcours plus globale et la
vidéo va venir à certains moments du
dispositif où l'élève va être bloquée et
a besoin justement de ce qui est dans la
vidéo pour pouvoir arriver au résultat
final qui est une production qui peut
être une carte un tableau de synthèse
rapport écrit une présentation orale et
donc la vidéo il est obligé de la
regarder mais d'utiliser un c'est pas
juste
oui il est regardé de nom oui j'ai
besoin de trucs donc là il faut bien
préciser aussi aux élèves ce qu'on
attend d'eux et ceux qui doivent aller
chercher dans la vidéo pour les
mobiliser un peu plus on peut aussi leur
demander c'est pas automatique
encore une fois une petite préparation
par rapport à cette vidéo ça peut être
juste vérifier les notes de leurs virval
tiens voici déjà un support dunlop
vous complétez avec si important et
l'enseignant peut regarder tient à ce
que les notes on était bien complété
donc on peut aussi formées en même temps
de manière très naturelle on peut
directement aider les élèves en
améliorer leur prise de notes mais ça
peut être aussi un petit questionnaire
moyens de bien faire un petit
questionnaire passe
le résultat du questionnaire qu'on fait
avec un google formulaire google forme
on développera dans une prochaine vidéo
aussi peut être utilisée en classe et
servir de support à une nouvelle
activité ou venir nourrir l'activité en
course et de l'ingénierie pédagogique et
la classe inversé c'est finalement un
type de tuyaux qui va nous permettre
d'amener l'eau de la source à l'arrivée
alors j'essaie que les vidéos n'excède
pas dix minutes ça c'est vraiment le
grand maximum
quand je vois que ça arrive à 10 minutes
je vraiment au montage je coupe je coupe
le couple je coupe pour être descendre
en dessous des 10 millions par exemple
le cours de géographie ces deux heures
semaine mon cours de sciences sociales
ces quatre heures donc là je me peux me
permettre un peu plus au niveau des
vidéos mais ils ont des cours de maths
des cours de français des cours de
langue qui leur demandent du temps donc
il ne viendrait pas à l'idée qu'il passe
une heure par semaine
une demi heure sur le cours de
géographie donc généralement il ya
maximum une vidéo par semaine à regarder
et celle ci j'ai c'est ce qu'elle soit
comprise dans une durée entre quatre et
six minutes ça c'est vraiment ma fenêtre
de tir
parfois il ya des sujets qu'on a besoin
de développer en plus donc en plus
j'essaie pour vraiment qu'ils les
titiller ce qui est une petite accroche
dans ces vidéos
donc il faut essayer de vraiment
ramasser le prouve le propos pour que ce
soit le plus synthétique possible en
fait les vidéos peuvent paraître
fantaisiste parfois mais j'essaie de la
fantaisie soit à la fin comme ça si
l'élève décroche c'est pas grave il a
compris que l'essentiel est passé ça
c'est vraiment très important je pense
la durée des vidéos parce qu'en plus de
la petite préparation ça va leur faire
dix quinze minutes qui doivent consacrer
au cours plus les autres courts ben là
ça devient ingérable pour les élèves et
la classe inversée finalement ça devient
un fardeau à la fois pour les élèves et
pour l'enseignant donc voilà il faut
être à la fois ambitieux dans son
dispositif
mais il faut être raisonnable aussi et
de ne pas arriver avec des blocs comme
ça indigeste finalement que les élèves
regardent et ne savent pas ce qu'il faut
ce qu'il faut faire
j'ai fait le tour de ma façon de voir et
de pratiquer dans les grandes lignes la
classe inversée dans de prochaines
vidéos je vous montrerai les différents
outils que j'utilise mais aussi des
exemples de dispositifs et si vous en
avez vu quelques-uns quelques vidéos de
que j'avais déjà fait qu'ils m'ont servi
mais on ira vraiment beaucoup beaucoup
plus loin dans l'analyse de 1
ou deux dispositifs dans le cadre de
cette semaine de la classe inversée je
vous remercie pour votre attention je
vous remercie pour tous les gens qui y
mots que vous avez à l'égard de ces
vidéos et de cette chaîne je vous
remercie et à très bientôt donc nous
tous
[Musique]